, TRILLIONS OFAS
AFTER SPENDING THE LAST 17 YEARS
UNDERGD, NO ONE IS MEX
THAN MY
NEXTUEIT
NU
JOINS BUN
FOR SKIPPING D.
BREAKFAST AND GETTING READY FOR
THIS EXPERIENCE.
>> I AM READY.
N' EG A BUNOT LY
SINCE I WAS 3 WHEN A
REIT GETTING SO MUCHOF C
PRESS.
SORE A OF
IMPORTANT MES A
PLFORM FOR.
EATING INSECTS I T
FUTUREANTHE PAST
OFANITY AS
>> LET'SOURE G TO DO HERE
YOU WALK ME THROUGH THIS. SOME E
SO C
>>ASICALLY, PICK WHICHEVER ONEWT
>> SHOULD ME THEM FIRST?
>> NO.ES TM HA WANT TO NAME
ANYTHING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
EATING.
>> I'LL NAME ONE BERMAN.
TO ROLL IT TH WSEAWEED.
E N SOME
GLOVES HERE.
ERFECT.
RITE WHITNEY "I BELIEVE EATING
INSECTS IS
I HAELLECTUAL AND CULINARY
CURIOSITY ABOUBUT I'M EROU
BUGS.
S
UN HUSBAND IS NOT GOING
TO KISS ME FOR A WEE
>> I G N KISSINGYOUR
SO D.
>>RE.
UNDERSTAND.'L DN
ISYOE
Y ON
SO THERE YOU GO.
Y JOKING
DO I REALLY HAO EAT A LIVE
>> IAS KIDDING.
>> FRED SURVIVES ANOTHER DAY.
>> BERMAN, CICADA VE.
HE HAD ME IN
SEGMENT.E GOIND OF
I WAS LIKE WAS PART  ASSIGNMENT,
BUT I'M HERE TO DO MWORK
>> YOU'RE ABOUT TO EATD
CICADAS.
O EXCITED YET.
I THINK THIS WAALLY GOOD
FOR HIL ME IATLIVE ONES BECAUSEE
GR
>> ARE YOU READY?OVER HERE AS
IT'S LCH>> DO VEOUMOUTH?